Good morning.
Good morning to, good morning, sir. Sorry for morning, sir.
Good morning, sir. Sir, in joining this good morning, sir.
Good morning. Good morning, sir. Good morning. Morning, sir.
Good morning, sir. Sir, I may have problem in joining, sir.
Yeah,
You answer.
I,
I was, I was not able to join from my phone.
I have to transfer my tab laptop everywhere.
Correct, correct. So, no,
it's struggling somehow Chatta helped me to join.
Yeah. Director is also joining in a while.
Meanwhile, I'll start.
Yes.
Okay. So we were, last time,
we were almost at this.
Yes. Let me go back a little bit here.
Okay, so last time we were talking about this, uh,
perceptron and, uh,
this would, okay.
Okay. So last time we were talking about this perceptron,
we got, this is the building block of neural network.
The story started with a single perceptron.
So it is very important
to understand the way perceptron works,
and we understood it, I guess, uh, for all of you.
Also, it was quite easy that perceptron, uh, this, this,
this is this processing unit here.
It accept the input along with the weight,
so it accept the weighted input.
You can say that. So we do hear the weighted sum, WIXI,
and when, then we add the bias
and we, uh, once we add this weighted sum plus bias,
we pass it through the activation function.
Activation function will decide what will, with the output,
which is coming from this particular perceptron.
So we had seen the demo,
and uh, there we also talked about what happened if,
if we have the bias, which is being added to this,
uh, weighted sum.
Okay? And, uh, how, how, here in this,
these two slide, we have seen that one.
What is the importance of the bias?
That, that also we have, um, uh, understood, uh,
with this particular slide.
Okay? And we said that bias brings the flexibility for,
for the perception,
because sometimes suppose given the set of input
and set of weights, we are not getting our desired input.
Then there will be one more parameter, which can be,
which can help us, uh, to, to get the,
the desired output, right?
So bias also is also a parameter, which we learn, uh,
during the training of this perceptron.
And, and then we were talking, um, I guess we were talking
a little about this, uh, decision boundary.
Fine. So first of all, how do we write the equation
for this perceptron?
It was like, suppose we have three inputs, X node X one,
X two, where X node, it represents the bias which we have
fixed as one for the simplicity.
We are giving the similar kind of notation so that
we will not treat bias separately from this weighted sum.
So from now on, what we'll do is this submission,
WIXI includes the bias term also,
only thing is x no will represent the bias,
which will be always one.
Okay? And, uh, this, this weight anyway, we have
to learn, okay, where we are.
So just to, uh, for the simplicity,
we have added this X node in terms of the B, right?
So my equation becomes then W node x node W one,
X one WX two.
And because X node is known, uh,
we can substitute the value here, one W node,
whatever is the value we can substitute here
and then rest of the equation, we can solve it
for either X one or X two.
We will get the, uh, we will get the, uh, equation in terms
of the X two or in terms of the X one, fine.
Then you can easily plot a line.
For example, here we have solve it for X two.
Then for every X one we can get what is the X two.
And hence you have the, um, uh, decision boundary,
which is plotted as you can see that.
So this we have done, so we understood
how this perception trick algorithm works.
So the main idea was, so you pick any random set
of the weights for WNW one, W2,
and as you will, uh, as you will choose any random set
of weight, you will get a decision boundary for that.
Now, with respect to the decision boundary,
you pick any random point, you will have multiple points.
For example, I have here this 1, 2, 3 points.
It is being shown here.
I can either pick this green point
or this blue point, or this green point.
I mean, it's random. So we don't have any control.
So randomly we are going to pick one point
and we'll see that side
of the line or not.
Okay? So if it is at the correct side, we are not going
to do any change in the line.
If it is not at the correct side, then we have
to update these parameters, W north, W one, W2.
Okay. Once we update this parameter,
we'll get a new line, right?
And then for, again, for the new line,
we'll pick next one more random points.
And we are going to continue this process as long
as you are not going to get the complete, uh, the,
either your number of aps are reached
or you, you have separated the data into two class clearly.
So that, that is the, that is this algorithm, right?
So this update parameter works only in the case
of the misclassification, not in the class of, uh, uh,
not in the case of, uh, correct classification.
And hence, uh, after that we have seen, uh, some,
some visualization as well
as the percept drawn trick demo as well.
So this much we had covered in the previous class.
So if you have any queries so far, uh, uh,
I mean you can ask us
and then we'll go little more detail for the,
what is the problem with this percept on trick algorithm?
Any queries so far,
What is the, uh, activation function called in case
of a percept transfer?
Is, is there a specific name to it?
By default? It is, uh, step function, right? By default.
Uh, this f what you're seeing is, uh,
but as I said, it's quite flexible.
Everything is flexible in the neural network.
You can change this f also, it i going for forward,
I'll show you that.
If I want my output to be in terms of the probability,
then a step function will not help,
because step function will give either zero
or one as an output,
but I want the probability as an output,
so I can change this function as sigmoid,
which gives the output between zero and one.
So it's quite flexible,
but, uh, so far we have seen this f
as a stiff function only.
Yeah.
Any other query?
Okay. So now, um,
now let, let us talk a little bit about the problem
of the perceptron.
So per perceptron, uh,
Uh, Sunil, I'm here.
Yes, it's, Uh, I can, uh,
handle this, uh, process. Yes, sir.
Yes, sir. Yeah. So, uh, I just,
I will take few minutes and uh, just go to the next slide.
This one second. Uh, no, I think you can, uh,
just now I compiled a new set of slides.
You can upload them. There are some error here and
Oh, okay. Okay. Yes,
sir.
Because this is linearly.
Ah, right. That last time you had talked, uh, that, uh,
sequence of the slide, I guess,
Hold on slightly.
Ah, yes, yes. No, this is the correct slide.
Now I just modified,
I'll present now. Yes.
Yeah. So go to the first, uh, previously,
previously, previously, please.
Yes. Ah, see, uh, good morning all.
Uh, see, I just briefly started this point in the last
session that, uh, I think, uh,
there was an important question.
Uh, um, they know what will be the possible
output function that we can use in the neural network
by default, as Dr.
Sunil mentioned, it is a step function,
but later we will see, based on, on certain requirements,
we can change those output functions.
But what is most important is up
to this point when we were explaining that, uh,
with the help of a perceptron neural model,
we have incorporated the, um, learning into the,
uh, neural neuron since we have incorporated, uh,
then it automatically learns the weight
parameters from the data.
But when they saw that it works, for some cases,
it doesn't work for the other cases, then they saw that
the possible broad categorization that is,
if the classes are linearly separable, the data points
of the, suppose there are two classes.
If the, the data points
of the two classes are linearly separable, linearly,
separable means, suppose if I take a two dimension thing,
which is the most common one we do, uh, if the data points
of the two classes are separated by a straight line,
then they're called as a linearly separable.
If I go for two dimension, three dimension,
that line becomes a plane.
If it can be separated by a plane data point,
then they're linearly separable.
If, if the, uh, data points
of different classes are linearly separable, then the,
the perceptron learning, whatever we explained
so far, uh, works.
Um, however, there are a significant number
of machine learning tasks
or pattern aggression tasks where the classes
may not be linearly sufferable.
And the easiest example is our logic gates
that we have studied XR gate and XR gate.
They're not linearly supportable.
I will show in the next, uh, following slide,
suppose if I take a, uh, a truth table of r,
simple R gate or ungate.
So 0, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0 1, 1 for R gate except zero, zero,
all others are output is one.
So now it forms two class zero and one another two classes.
Now, if you plot it in a two dimensional plane
and C, you can easily group them middle into two classes.
Same is true with and r and nine.
Whereas when I go to XR
or XR gate, suppose if I take XR gate 1, 0 0
or one, those cases, it'll be 1 0 0 1 1, it'll be
zero in that case, if you try to encircle them
to make a two different clusters, it is not possible.
And those are called as, they're not linearly separable
or linearly inseparable.
We say again, linearly inseparable also.
So this inseparable class, uh,
the perceptron will not be able to learn.
Learn means you don't find an optimal set
of weight parameters.
Uh, which forums which represent that linear hyperplane
to separate the data points of the two classes,
always the line will be wandering year,
and there it never read convergence.
Okay? So then, uh,
in the linearly inseparable classes, they saw no okay with,
um, one perceptron is not possible.
Then they went for, uh, um,
another layer of perceptron prior to the perceptron that,
uh, we are using in the output layer.
And with the help of those previous layer perceptron,
we can construct the hyper surfaces.
They're not anymore sight lines or, uh, hyper planes.
Um, they will be, uh, curve surfaces lightning, which can,
uh, bend like thread to separate the two classes.
That is what, uh,
and that is where the complexity
of the neural network increases.
But we start, uh, getting into a, where we can also deal
with the linearly inseparable classes.
And that is where the, you know,
multi-layer perception journey starts.
That is what I'm going to explain as a part of this.
And if the data points are not linearly separable,
um, then they're called as
hard problems from a simple perception point of view.
That is the standard name given in the neural network.
Rere, they're called as hard problems
or representation problems.
So that is what we are going to discuss. Next slide.
So here what I was explaining,
let us consider a simple two class classification problem
or binary linearly separable classes.
And I'm taking a simple perceptron
now in a two dimensional plane,
we are showing the distribution of the data point.
This xx all belong to one class,
and the circles belong to other class,
and they're represented
by a two dimensional vector X one equal
to E one, X two equal to eight.
This is a two dimensional vector as the data point.
All these X classes are having the corresponding X one,
X two in this range, whereas, uh, for, uh, the,
the circle classes, uh, X one and X two are in this range.
That is how they're different classes.
Now, suppose I want to, what is expected is if I am given,
these are letters, assume
that these are training data points.
Now, when these data points are given, I have
to learn the characteristics of data points such that no,
I in future, if I get a data point to either X class,
I should be able to separate this from this circle class.
That means to say I should say this belongs to the Class X.
Or if a data point you get
during testing from year circle class,
I should say this belongs to class.
Oh, okay. So for that, I have
to learn this operation boundary between the two class,
for example, initially em equal to zero,
that is the initial, uh, iteration
where I will have a random weights fixed for W one equal
to em for the neuron
and with the random weights, if I compute the, uh, equation
that is I equal
to one two M-W-I-X-I minus theta equal to zero.
That equation, if I compute, this is the equation
of the strike line.
That is how it comes. Okay?
You can see that with emmic equal to zero.
We talked before starting the training.
Now what is happening is some
of the O samples are also misclassified as excess samples
because have both this are treated as one class.
Below this are treated as another class.
Now you start the training process equal to one m, equal
to two, like that M equal to 10.
If I see this is the strike line still there is a
misclassification M equal to 20.
Randomly this line is coming.
There is nothing like, no, uh, like a cant lever.
It slowly grows down or something.
Every iteration, the weights, uh, changes.
So accordingly, uh, means
because depending on the weight value,
the line can wander in the surface.
Emmic equal to 30 is you can see emmic equal to four T.
This line is coming.
There is no unique line, uh, present
to separate the data points.
You can see now in this place,
there are infinite lines possible to separate these two.
We'll start the training to stop the training process
as soon as we receive the reach.
This point, there is a call to t like this.
Any, I arrive at a solution where
there's no unique solution,
multiple solutions possible in
the training it ready process.
As soon as I reach a place where ideally, you know,
I separate all the training samples like
this, it's a wishlist.
I'll stop the training process in practice if it is
not possible, and that is the case.
Most of the cases, because the samples are not nicely
separated like this, at that point, we are going
to stop at a place where I reached the minimum
point, minimum point.
And then beyond that, uh, there is no further decrement.
That's what I do. Okay?
So a two class problem,
which are linearly separable with a simple perception that,
uh, we discussed so far, using that through a it process
of learning the weights,
we can finally arrive at a place like just for example,
m equal to 40, where I am able
to separate the data points of that.
Uh, the two classes, when we arrive at that,
we say we have actual convergence of the perception lab.
Okay? This is a no simple case, which is, uh, linearly
cases, any doubt here to any
of you, any of you,
Yes, sir. Uh, have
it. Yeah, sir.
Uh, what is the convergence criteria
that we need to, uh, set
Look convergence criteria means ideally, you know,
in the training samples,
I know in the classification problem of pre each
of the data points are given that these are the,
this belongs to class four, and this belongs to class X.
Okay? Now, suppose I apply all the training samples
and try to check from the learned, uh, hyper surface,
whether it is correctly classifying or not, okay?
If it's correctly classifying, then it is fine.
You calculate the performance a hundred percent ideally
should get classified.
But of course there are practical challenges with that.
No, the neural network may over fit for
that training samples.
That's why no people convert this
training set into two portion.
One is the training set, maybe 80% under 10
to 20% value validation set.
We see that validation data points are taken
and, uh, check with their class labels nominated
by the learned perception.
If it correctly nominates labels,
then we say we have convergences achieved or
otherwise, no, it's below certain
in practical cases may be 2% error or something.
Then we stop.
Thank you, sir. Okay, next slide.
Uh, can the percept be used
to solve a multi-class problem?
We are only dealing here
With, uh, thi this, this is the next slide.
I'm going for that multi-class.
I put it, I'll explain that
before that, uh, one more hand was rise,
Sir. Um,
so what the bias there?
So, uh, so choosing the bias will influence the,
um, where, where you convert, right?
Ah, ah, so, um, so are we gonna start with the, let's say
in this specific case, in the previous slide,
in this specific case, can we start with the wire of zero
and, uh,
the origin, right? So, uh,
Yes. So ideally
you see even the biases also learned from the
data points, okay?
That is why. Suppose if you require, you know,
recall the equation for the perception i one, um,
I equal to one two MWXI minus theta equal to zero
or equal to theta.
That is the inequality or minus theta equal to zero.
Now, the theta can be expressed as W zero into X zero,
where X zero is not the actual data point just to have no.
Now I have a, uh, equality equation w equal to I equal
to zero to M where W zero x zero represents your theta.
And, uh, in that, uh, this W zero X
and always the, the x zero is kept as, uh, minus one
because that is minus theta.
Is there threshold?
I'll keep it as minus one, always that input X zero equal
to minus one, because this is not coming
from external data point.
Now the, the learning equation is, uh,
WXI minus the equal to zero.
Now minus is set as x, not equal to minus one.
Now I have to learn that, uh, theta part, which is nothing
but w not, uh, that learned as a process
of equation, that equation.
Okay? Okay, Soman, thank you. Yeah, thank you sir.
So now I have a
Question. Yeah,
Sir?
Uh, in support vector machine, um, so we select a hyperplane
that maximizes the margin, right?
Using the closest, uh, support, uh, vectors. Yes.
So here also, does it maximize the margin
or it just, uh, separates both of the classes, sir?
Wonderful, wonderful question.
Uh, there, here it is not a maximum margin classifi, that's
where I told no, there are infinite solutions possible.
For example, sun, we'll go back to the previous slide.
If there have been a maximum, uh, suppression classified,
this a equal to 40 line, no,
should I come exactly in the center?
Yes. So that, no, all the samples are equally distanced from
positive or negative example, but here in the neural
network, there's no maximum margin classifi.
So it can, as for all the given training data point,
it is able to achieve a separation.
We stop it there.
Okay, sir. Got it, Thank you. Okay, next, next.
So as long as they're linearly supportable,
even if there are multiple classes, we can, uh, no
build a perception classifier.
What happens, for example, here
you have this input layer, input layer.
These are linear units. The output functions are linear.
That means to say they don't really perform the, uh,
perception function are neuron function.
They're only fan out terminals.
Like, you know, if we are from electronics
or something, no, you have one terminal.
From there I can draw wise to other
because the, the faster dimension has
to be fed into all the neurons in the perception layer.
Similarly, second dimension also needs to be fed into
all the neurons in the pa.
That is where that the input layer is non-existent from a
neuron function point of view
or a machine learning task point of view,
they're only feeding units.
See, now, you can see now in the output layer, the number
of neurons in the output layer.
That is the perceptron layer.
Hard limiting unit means you have a step function
as the output function.
When I do this one, perceptron is there for one class.
Now, in the example, if you see there are three classes, x,
O, and dots.
These are three different classes.
Now, one perceptron say letters.
First perceptron is for x,
second person is the perceptron is for O,
and the third percent perception is for dot.
Now, while training the neuron for the excess sample,
my goal is the excess samples data points becomes the
positive examples and the data points
of all other remaining classes becomes
the negative examples.
Now, my goal is I have to identify an hyper surface,
which separate these excess samples
with all other rest points.
You can see this right line next to the x, that slant line.
That will be the, um, the, uh,
hyper surface, which is separate the data points of X
with the both O and dots.
That is what when I'm training the perception
of the X class, I use that equation
representing the hyperplane for this si uh, uh, perceptron,
which is this slant vertical, uh, slant line.
That equation will satisfy this inequality condition, okay?
Separating this with the rest.
Similarly, when I go
to the second neuron circle versus the other two point,
the other opposite X line will be useful that,
and the third neuron is the horizontal line will be
useful in that way.
This you can extend to the end number of classes as long
as the classes are linearly supportable.
You can put that many perceptrons in the output layer,
and each perceptron represent one class,
and the rest sample acts as the negative examples.
Then by ative process, you can arrive at convergence
and it is assured
that convergence we achieve in the
linearly supportable classes.
They is Does it answer your question?
Uh, yes sir. Yeah, Goro? Yeah. Thank you.
So the, this we are shown for three classes you can extend
to any number of classes as long
as they're linearly supportive.
Okay? Next one, subject
For one perception. It
can classify only two, right? It cannot
Classify yes, it basically taxes a, uh,
binary classifier. Okay? Then we
Are breaking down this multi-class problem into a binary
class classification.
Uh, by means, uh, see, it means of this rajesh,
when you say, when I'm breaking down into a binary class,
in case of binary class,
I am not seeing a conventional support vector machine.
If I go to support vector machine, yes,
basically it is designed
as a binary classifier for every class.
I separately trying a binary classifier.
Then I have an ensemble
of binary classifiers to deal multi-class.
Whereas in the multi perception we don't do in perception,
we don't do that even though we designate one perception
for each binary class,
but they're simultaneously fed into all the layers and kind.
Okay? That is how in one go, I try
and assemble of binary classifier in the percept.
Okay, fine.
Next, Ah, now we are moving into the case of,
uh, linearly inseparable classes.
Same you can see now, um,
actually it is binary linearly inseparable classes.
Not multi-class, sorry for
that binary linearly inseparable class.
You see the production process of the data points at
that same xx are there,
but they're distributed in two direction.
Similarly, uh, these circles are there,
they're distributed in two different points.
They're only binary class, not multi-class.
Sorry, I will change the title. Okay?
You, you see now, uh, even though the spaces are available
among them, you try to see, suppose if I take em equal
to zero line, only one portion of the circles are put
as one class, whereas the other portion
of circles are included as a negative exam.
Similarly, when I go to say I go to iCal to 20 line,
half of these samples from X
and half of the samples from circles are given as one class,
the others are given another.
So you can go on putting this, any number
of iterations you do, the hyper surfaces
that are getting generated,
the slight trains which are getting generated
will never be able to classify all the samples
and such things are term as, uh,
linearly inseparable classes.
Okay? One way of doing that is just to give an as one
imagine aro surface available straight line is not possible
cur surface available, which can, uh, put a contour
around this excess separately
and the circles, uh, in a separate, for example, some
of you have done CARNA math in the digital, uh,
combination logic circuit simplification.
We used to put the, you know, curves
to separate two classes.
The same nature should evolve here, okay?
To simple hyper planes.
Linear hyper planes doesn't help in separate.
I think you should get this idea to your mind.
No, you try in any way, you'll not be able
to put a limited hyperplane.
I need an nonlinear, uh, hyperplane two, uh,
cover the samples for each class separate.
Okay? Next slide.
First of all, you see I was telling in the opening remark
that uh, this is, um, um, um,
logical under gate
where 0 1 0 0 1 0, the output is zero
that I'm showing it as x,
and uh, for one, one the output is one
that I'm throwing it as a circle.
Now, I can put a straight line between one and O
and X two, separate that these are linearly supportable.
You come to, uh, this is XR gate
or 0 1 1 0.
It is 1 0 0 1 1. It is zero.
Now you see, if you put a straight line anywhere,
you'll not be able to support it.
These are linearly inseparable classes.
So for that, I need to have a, you know,
a ellipsoid like thing which will cover 0 1, 1 0 line
and, uh, half el lymph side, this side
and ole side, this side so
that they belong to another class.
That is how we need to create surfaces
for covering the data point software given
linearly inseparable classes.
So, so for that purpose, a single layer perception,
which was there, which is creating linear hyper planes,
will not be possible to deal
with the linearly inseparable classes.
That is where the next two will go.
Ah, now this figure is very important.
This is a two layer, uh, network.
Two layer network means one layer, input layer is there.
That means you say there is only a single layer perceptron,
a single layer perceptron is there.
Now, if I take an exclusive r ga, no,
this is the linear hyperplane that separates, okay?
Now you see a portion of the class, same class A
or class zero is left out and put as a part of B only.
That is not, uh, uh, possible.
No, you cannot do any convergence.
On the other hand, you see slightly next row.
I am inserting one more perceptron layer prior
to the earlier perceptron layer that we are discussing.
It is a three layer network input layer
and output layer was there earlier in
between the input and output layer.
I'll insert one more perceptron layer,
and now if you consider each perceptron,
they create only linear hyper planes.
But if I combine the outputs of two
or more, um, uh,
perceptrons in the next perceptron layer,
you get a modified hyper surface.
That is what supposedly in this case, what happens if I take
previous two layers of perceptron.
If I pull, if I see the hyper surface at the output
of the output layer, their convex surfaces
will be created like this.
Now, you can see now just like car map I was showing
the data point belong to classier are all in within one
surface, and BB are getting separated.
Let me just say, um, this is a convex, convex surface means
if I take two data points within that convex surface,
you connect a line, the line connecting the two data points
will lie within that convex surface, within
that surface itself, such as called as a convex surface.
Okay? Alternatively, you come to the next example, uh,
classes with measured region.
This a car-like region.
Now suppose if I take a a two layer network, I try
to build a surface, but still here in this case,
these are non convex surfaces.
The data are distributed in a non convex manner.
If I take two data points within that, b,
I can connect the lines,
the line will be outside that surface.
That is a non convex case.
So if I take a three layer network in which one is input
layer, which is not participating in the classification
task, there are two perceptron layers.
With the help of the middle perceptron layer, I will be able
to achieve a modified hyper surface, non convex hyper,
sorry, um, non-linear hyper surface at
the output perceptron.
One cases I can do, a convex surfaces can be created.
Now, they're not linearly separable,
but the data points of each class form a convex surface.
At that point of time, I will be able
to still construct hyper surfaces,
which can separate the data points of each of the class.
So typical construction of the surfaces can be
as simple like this, or it can be like this
or the last vertical region,
most gentle region shape it can.
So the shape that is taken constructed like this
for the last column, if you see there is one, uh, strike,
small straight line, another straight line portion,
other straight line portion like this rapid is like thing it
is happening and that
this is one slight line from one new,
one perceptron in the previous layer.
The other portion is from other, uh,
perceptron in the second layer,
other perceptron there under the output layer.
I combine all of them depending on the number
of neurons output you're combining this one,
the surface nature changes,
but in a two layer perceptron network
or a three layer network,
always you create convex hyper surfaces
and those cla linearly inseparable machine learning tasks
where the data points of each class are lying in the
convex manner, then you can deal with them with the help
of two layer network.
But we are shown in the classes with measured region
or more general region,
it is the two layer network can only handle this convex
surfaces column where third
and fourth column no are whatever, uh, fourth
or fifth column, which are non-con services.
It cannot be handled by two layer
network or three layer network.
That's why you go to the four layer network,
and I'm telling four layer, sorry for that confusion.
That is input layer you have to neglect.
So three perception layers are there
when three perception layers are there.
Now the first perception layer
will feed into the second perception layer.
The hyper surfaces are convex surfaces,
and those convex surfaces are fed into the output perception
layer, combination of the convex surfaces.
We can create non convex surfaces.
Also, with that, you can see the most general cases
also can be handled.
So that is how the concept
of multi-layer perceptron was evolved
from a single layer perceptron, which was suitable only
for linearly sufferable classes.
Okay? So that is how the thing, any, any doubt
or clarifications here.
Okay, we'll go to the next. Uh, so
The difference between the, the answerable three based
approach versus this is, uh,
Can you please repeat, can we louder?
So, uh, for multi-class scenarios, right?
We have Ansible, uh,
three based models as well as this, right?
So the difference is in terms of the weightage learning,
is it, uh, uh, or,
Or anything? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, you have my the three basic approach.
No, you are putting certain, uh, uh, no,
like a discretization you are doing right,
and some node I take a decision.
So based on that, no, I exclude a possibility of other set
of weight parameters, which can come
in a quantization manner.
I'm going in the decision phase, whereas the neural network,
it's a, a continuous way of exploration.
So, uh, so that's the reason why the other Ansible team
based model doesn't learn these kind of, uh, nonlinear, uh,
non, uh, linearly nonlinear approachable dataset.
Hmm, correct, correct.
So that's where, no, this is a more, uh, realistic way of,
uh, or more complex way of trying to learn
and it'll help better.
Okay, thanks. Okay, perfect. Next slide.
So this I have told already, I just, uh, a two layer feed
for neural network with hard limiting threshold units.
That is a step function in the output.
Uh, this one there can only solve the linearly pattern.
Classification problems or machine learning problems
in a two layer feed for a network is also called
as a single layer perception,
because input layer,
only since the output layer is only non-linear units,
whereas input layer is linearly inputs.
So as I was mentioning,
there are many problems which are not linearly acceptable,
and hence they're not representable
by a single layer perceptron, not representable means
I'm not able to find a hyper surface, linear hyper surfaces,
which can separate the, uh, examples of, uh, the classes.
And these representable problems are called
as hard problems, uh, the name given as hard problems.
So if the output of the second layer
combined forming another layer, that's what the,
I put the two layers from the input side.
The first perception layer I'm getting
that is called as a second layer.
If it is combined forming another layer,
then any convex region can be formed
by this operating surfaces in the output little perception
layer, I can form any convex surface.
So a convex region is one in which a line joining any two
points is entirely confined to the region itself.
That XR gate is a convex, uh, region problem case.
Okay, next. So the number
of units in the second layer, that is
that middle perception layer we are thinking no,
determines the shape of the dividing surface.
And number of units in the third layer will
decide the number of classes.
That is like a linear support number of classes,
depends on the number of units in the output layer.
And the three layer network is still not general enough
as it doesn't guarantee that
the class regions in the patterns of space form
ConX region in all cases as shown that, uh,
that current is a cashew like structure, no,
which is a non convex also.
Okay? Uh,
and it can have a complicated non convex region also.
So that is where, uh, intersection
of linear hyper planes in the three layer network can only
produce convex surfaces.
However, however, you have one more layer of perception.
The intersection of convex regions may produce any non
convex region also.
Okay? Uh, so this is nothing
to do with the neural networks.
People from the mathematics, they brought this concept
that no, what happens if I try to interconnect
the two linear hyper planes?
What it'll, what surfaces it creates?
And from there, if I combine such surfaces,
what it'll create that concept they brought
and they showed that if I go on putting this layered, uh,
perceptron, then I may be able to achieve the, uh,
dealing with the machine learning tasks where
the classes are not linearly supportable.
So that is where they told adding one more layer of units
to combine the outputs of the third layer canele surfaces,
which can separate even non convex regions also.
So that is where, uh, the, uh, if you go back to the table,
uh, Sunil, just, uh, here, see this is a four layer network.
I have three perceptron layers at the first layer output,
I get linear hyper plates.
At the second layer of the perception,
I get the convex surfaces as the hyper surface.
If I combine convex surfaces at the output layer,
I can perform, uh, non convex regions also can be created
a both three layer network at the output
of the first perception layer.
You get the, uh, linear hyper planes combining them,
you get the convex surface.
Whereas I have only two layer network,
only one perception layer, only linear hyper planes.
So this is from the, uh,
mathematical theory people have observed without
worrying about the neural networks from the, it's not from
derived from the network interaction of the surfaces,
how we can from simple linear hyper planes,
how I can construct, uh, complex hyper planes, non, non, uh,
linear hyper planes that based on
that they have all this structure.
Okay, next, next.
So then all these
which are not linearly supportable, they're called as,
they cannot be represented by a single layer perceptron.
Accordingly, they're called as hard problems.
So to take care of these hard problems.
Finally, the structure proposal was a four layer network
with input layer consistent linear units.
And the other three layer consisting
of hard limiting non-linear units
can perform any complex pattern classification task
as machine learning task.
Thus, all the hard problems mentioned earlier can be handled
by such a multi-layer feed forward neural network
with non-linear units.
Such a network is called as a multi-layer perception, where
the except input layer in the three layers,
we have multi-layer perseverant aligned as layers.
Um, so then similar behavior is expected from a
multi-layer field when the output functions
of the units are continuous, non-linear function,
such as sigmoid function.
Also, you can get that saved so that, uh,
that illustrations have shown.
Next slide. Uh, okay, uh, previous slide, uh, just
to summarize, starting from a single layer,
which we discussed in the previous session, which was able
to deal with the, uh, linearly classes.
Now conceptually we have come up with a framework, uh,
where I have a a three multi-layer perceptron network
or a four layer feed for a network
where input layer is a linear, you can deal
with hard problems also,
and that is called as a multi-layer perceptron.
Multi-layer perceptron means you have more than two layers,
three multi three layer layers of perceptance out there.
Then it is called a multilayer.
Three are more, it is called a multilayer.
So that is the conceptual framework.
We will see it has its own challenges. We will see it.
Okay, next, uh, Sunil kindly take,
Yes, sir, thank you.
Alright, so, uh, now, uh, we have understood
what is the problem with the perceptron, that what happens,
uh, if there is a non
linearly separable data set will come into the picture.
So that time, a single preceptor network
that has clearly explained the one more problem, uh, uh,
what we can see in, in this case with this figure that
although for the linearly separable data, you may have the
A hyperplane like hyperplane A, hyperplane B,
which is clearly separating the two class of data,
it is very difficult to say that whether hyperplane A
is the best one or hyperplane B, B is the best one.
That is, that is another problem, right?
And that's where, uh, when Brenda was asking this question
that, okay, uh, that, uh, a maximum margin,
whether it considers
or not, sir, has told no, it,
it doesn't consider the maximum margin.
So, which happens in the case
of support vector machine, right?
So yes, you may get a hyperplane, which will be able
to separate the two class of data,
but whether this hyperplane is the best hyperplane
or not, that perception cannot tell you, okay?
That, that, uh, what, what you must have seen in the
support vector machine.
So that is another problem with the perception.
So, but, uh, we, we can always calculate the loss.
So someone, uh, uh, asked that, okay,
how do we, uh, converge?
Uh, so, uh, sir had said that, okay,
whenever you have the a hundred plus, uh, a hundred percent,
uh, uh, uh, correct classification
for a particular hyperplane, you can say that, okay,
that type, that hyperplane is doing a good job,
whether it is the best hyperplane
or not, that we can cannot answer, uh uh, right?
But then yeah, it is able to separate the two class
of data completely, and
that we can always estimate using the loss function, right?
So, uh, we can always calculate for a given hyperplane
what is the total loss, right?
And, uh, uh, based on that, we can estimate that, okay,
whether that hyperplane is good or not.
For example, maybe this dotted hyperplane,
what you can see here, hyperplane, DC,
and you can calculate the loss for this also total loss,
and for this also, but obviously the loss for hyper being B
and a would be zero, because these two are the hyperplane,
which are able to separate the two class of data completely.
So yes, loss function, uh, that's
where it comes into the picture to tell that, okay,
which line is good and how much it is good, right?
And the loss function, what we use
with the perceptron is a hinge style loss function, which,
which, which we also use with the support vector machines.
So it's very simple loss function, say
that the loss value will be zero if
the prediction is a correct, correct prediction.
So if, uh, y uh,
dot w transpose TW transpose t is a prediction, okay?
Uh, whether it is a plus one
or minus one, these two class of data,
and y is the actual class.
So suppose you are, uh, trying to predict the actual class
as plus one and w transpose th plus one,
then this whole quantity will be positive.
So that means that you're at the right side,
so the loss will be zero in that case.
Now, suppose the wise equal to minus one
and w transpose TX is also minus one.
Then also it is positive.
Hence, you're again, still in the, um, um,
correct side for the negative class.
So in such cases, when you are doing the correct, uh,
classification loss is zero.
In such cases where you're not doing the correct
classification, this is the penalty, this is the loss.
What we say that, okay, this is the loss,
what we are getting.
So, but then if you see the update rule, we do not, uh, in,
uh, we are not using the loss function
to update the parameter.
Because once you are getting one line, for example,
you got this line, say that hyperplane d, now you have to,
next line, you have to change the parameters, right?
And suppose you get the hyperplane A.
So in order to get from hyperplane D to the next line
as hyperplane, a next plan as hyperplane a, uh,
we don't use the laws into, into the consideration, okay?
We, uh, update the parameter,
but we don't use the laws, uh, this, uh,
this hinge style loss into the consideration.
It is just for the, uh, finding whether the, uh, line,
what we have got is good, bad, how much bad, how much good
for that purpose, okay?
So that is one thing. Uh, same thing.
I, I've explained that what will happen when you're in the
correct region or you are in the, uh, other region.
So how this particular loss function will work.
This is just a geometric, uh, understanding for that.
Alright? So, uh, what I will do now
that whatever problem we have seen with the, uh,
non-linearly separable data with the single perceptron,
that we are going to visualize it
and we are going to code it, okay?
In PyTorch. So
that's the next thing what we are going to do.
But before that, I was also talking, uh,
that upper perceptron,
although initially it was used with the step function
where the output was zero
or one later, uh, if, suppose you want to change it
for some other kind of problem statement,
where the output is, say between zero
and one, okay, you can use it.
The only change, what we have to do is this part will work
as it is the weighted sum,
which also includes the bias, okay?
Which is here plus one.
So this is weighted sum will work as it is.
Now, after doing the weighted sum,
you will get the value ZZ you have to pass
to the activation function.
So instead of using activation function as step function,
now you will use the activation function
as sigmoid one divided by one plus E to the power minus Z.
And then obviously it'll give the value between zero
and one, enhance your output.
The y will be between zero
and one, like, like a probability, okay?
So you can change it. That is what I want to say.
And this is just a representation of that.
You can see that the, this is the, uh, uh, s shape curve,
what you will give get for the sig mite,
and the output is between zero and one on the y axis.
Whatever is the Z doesn't matter.
So that is one way you can, uh,
make this perceptron flexible
for the output of what you want.
So there are many other activation function for that matter.
For example, instead of using the activation function
as sigmoid, you can also use it at 10 H
and we'll be using the standard for some cases.
Uh, for example, suppose when we,
when we'll talk about the recurrent neural network there,
the people have used the, for the hidden layer,
they have used the 10 agent activation function
and how the 10 h uh, works.
So it takes Z What is z? Z is again the weighted sum.
What we are getting from the input side plus bias,
and that we are passing to this activation function.
It also gives, uh, uh, sorry, it, it gives, uh, the output
between minus one, two plus one.
You can see that the y xxi here,
it is ranging from minus one to plus one, whatever is the z,
Z can be positive, Z can be negative,
but the output will be square minus one to plus one.
It may be helpful in some cases.
We'll see that one when we use the recurrent neural network.
Similarly, we have another activation function called relu.
Now, relu, uh, is again, it takes Z
as an input, which is a weight sum.
And how, how does it work? It is a max Z zero.
So if the Z value is positive, say
that xxi, you concentrate here.
If the Z value is positive, the Y is
or the relu of Z, the that Z is that value itself.
So the Y is also that value itself.
So Z here, suppose it is 10, then Y also will be 10.
So that is, that is how it is.
Now, suppose, uh, Z is negative.
Suppose that is negative
because we don't have any control, right?
What will be the Z, Z depends on the input
and the weight, what you have defined.
It's a weighted sum of that.
So if suppose that is negative, in such cases it is, it is,
uh, it, its output will be zero.
So output will be on the, in this excess itself.
So that is how the relu activation function works.
And this relu activation function will see that,
although the relu has, uh,
people have used it in various networks,
but we'll see that in CNN with a convolution neur network,
people have, uh, used the radio activation function.
So, uh, that is, that is
how you can make this single perception flexible for
what kind of output you want.
Okay? Now, uh, with that,
let me now show you some visualization for the perceptron,
uh, which a single perceptron, uh, where it works for the
and and orate, but doesn't work for the ex orate, okay?
This we have already, uh, seen,
but now I'll show you the demo as well as the visualization.
Okay? So the first, first plot is for the,
and second plot is for the odd,
and third plot is for the xor.
You can see that the blue points represents the cla, uh,
the output one and the
white circles are representing the output zero.
So here you can have one, one line,
which is separating the blue and white.
Here you have one distorted red line
separating blue and white.
But here, you cannot have, that is
what sir was explaining sometime.
So I'll first show you the visualization of this.
So this is one, uh, website, uh,
which we can use to see this.
So what I'll do is I'll use the, uh, exor like data.
So this is exor like data, right?
So blue, you can see that blue, blue, uh,
and this orange, orange.
So you can treat it as like a, uh, it is like,
uh, uh, zero zero.
And this is one, one input.
And this is like, uh, uh, one zero,
and this is, uh, zero one.
Okay? So that is how it is that exhort like input. It is.
So now what we'll do is we want
to use the single perception.
So for single perceptron, first of all,
I'll remove all the hidden layer.
So you know, we have zero hidden layer.
You can see these two are my inputs,
X one, X two are my inputs.
I have zero hidden layer, and I, I have one output there.
This is the output layer, okay? Okay.
Now before this one, uh, let me use this data, set.
This data, this data set is linearly separable, right?
All blue are here, and all, all orange are here.
You then, uh, a single perceptron.
So you can treat this layer as a single perceptron,
where we have a single perceptron,
which does the weighted sum, uh, followed
by the activation function.
Okay? So now if, suppose we have this as a data,
which is a linearly separable data.
If I play this one, you can quickly see
that there is one thick white line which is able
to separate the two class of data clearly,
because it is a linearly separable data,
a single perceptron works for that, okay?
It may take some number of EPOCs epox number of hydration,
every iteration, it is changing the line
that we have already seen that how it does.
But then finally it'll con converge so that it'll be able
to separate the two class of the data.
But if I'll take this exor like structure,
and I will just play this, uh, and see the och it is going.
And every epoch, we are trying to do some change in the,
in the, uh, uh, uh, the, the line, what we want
to get from the single perceptron.
But you see that after running it for 900, so going
around thousand epochs.
Also, we are not able to separate the, um, uh,
these two classes clearly, right?
In fact, there is no such separation.
Also, we are not able to see, uh,
clear separation anywhere, anywhere.
So what we, I can do is just for the change, I will try
to change some other activation function
and we'll see if it, that will be able to help us.
So now I'm using the sigmoid, still
with the single perceptron
and see that there is no cell, no,
no change, which is happening.
So what I will do is, uh, uh, what that is,
what servers telling that single perception cannot, uh,
separate the nonlinearly separable data.
It's a heart problem. So then what we'll do is we'll try
to introduce one more layer, okay?
With more, we will try to introduce one more layer of the,
uh, um, hidden.
So this was the output layer, which was a single perceptron.
Now I have the one more hidden layer,
and there I have two neurons, and here I have one neuron,
and these two are the inputs.
Now, with this, I will, I'll just run this one.
I'll see that whether it is able
to separate these two glass of data or not.
Now you see that there's some
change which is happening, right?
So this, this region is, uh, we are able to get,
and this region also, uh, uh, it is,
it is creating one region over here, right?
Because we have once perceptron here, which is able
to separate, uh, get the line.
You can see this right? Once I, I will, uh, put here,
you see the mother some, some, some separation here, right?
Now, this particular, uh,
perceptron is doing some separation over this region
of this, uh, of this data set.
And this is what, what is coming,
but still this is not working well.
So what I will do is I will just try to change it to say,
uh, I'll send to, just to check that whether it is working
that in that case or not.
Now you see what is happening, almost similar kind of, uh,
uh, almost similar kind of, you see this, uh,
we are getting, um, so
after this, it won't change much, right?
Uh, what, what, we'll, what we'll do is, uh, let us see
that if, if 10 inch, if it can help us.
So you see that, right?
So it is able to make two different, uh, you can say this,
this kind of, um, reason,
but then complete separation, it is not able
to do completely, uh, it is not able to do, right?
So what, what what we can do is I will add one more layer
just for the, try that what happens, uh,
when we add layers by layer.
So that is what I was explaining.
So I'll add one more layer just to check that, okay?
Whether it is working, and then you can
play around this also.
In fact, instead of having one more layer,
I'll add one more neuron, oh, sorry, uh,
here one more neuron
and then I'll check whether what it is able to do.
Now you see that two inputs
with the three neurons at the hidden layer,
only one hidden layer, and then we have one output layer.
Now, this is the, this is the, uh, the,
like a hyperplane, uh, sort of a structure,
but obviously it is a curve.
Uh, it is, it is giving,
but it is able to do a better job just by adding one more,
one more neuron in the same hidden layer.
Okay? If I'll add one more, then you can see that this is,
uh, this is how, how, this is how it is given the,
um, separation.
So you see that e every neuron has some importance
and okay, every neuron you can see that it is trying
to capture, uh, some pattern in the data.
For example, this neuron has this, this, this is
what it is able to understand.
This is, uh, this neuron ha,
this perception has this understanding,
this understanding and all.
So together, when we are feeding their understand
to the next layer, this is what we are getting.
See now, see now this is how it has separated,
and it, it looks, it looks good also, right?
As compared to the layer. So this is the visualization.
So single perception was able, not able to do this job,
but then, uh, when we are having one, one head layer
with a few neurons are able
to separate this non-linearity separable data as well.
So now for then you can take any, any such, uh, you can say
that the arbitrary shape of the data like this,
where the blue are in the blue circle is different from the
author circle, right?
So it is able to do that
and you can check that, okay, how many, uh, neurons are
and how many layers are required for that.
Okay? So you see this here, maybe two neurons
end up with this, but then as soon we add one more, uh,
sorry, one more neuron in this first same hidden layer,
it is able to get that inner circle nicely.
Okay? So this is what visualization,
which I thought will give you some clear understanding that
what happen if we add one neuron
or we delete one neuron from it.
Now the, I will explain, uh, the exor, uh, problem,
the demo part, that what exactly, uh, happens, uh, how
to, how to, uh, write the code to see that, okay, the,
um, uh, single perceptron cannot solve the xor problem.
So here, there is a code I will connect.
So here we are importing all the packages from the
torch, right?
And back plot lift
because I want to plot some things
in this particular cell I am just defining my data for.
And so 0, 0, 0 1, 1, 0 1, 1, these are the tens.
Uh, this is the tensor for the, and x
and corresponding labels are like 0, 0, 0 1.
Similarly for, or similarly for xor.
So this line is for data creation.
And here we are just trying to plot, plot what plot.
And so this is the, and you can see that, right?
So zero, zero, this is one zero,
this is zero one, and this is one, one.
So this one, one is one rest all the blue.
You can see it is a class zero.
Similarly for, or, uh, you can see
that all The three are class one,
this blue point is Class zero.
And for xor, this is what we have the visualization.
Right now, what we have to do, we have to try
with a single perceptron, whether it is able to
separate the two class, class one, class, zero
or not, for all the three cases.
So what we have to do, first of all, I'm adding a bias
and bias, uh, as we mentioned earlier,
bias value x note is taken as one, okay?
Taken as one, uh, in all the cases.
So here, the, the bias, which I'm going to add
in each row one, so one column I have added.
So what I'm doing is for,
and which is initially at 0, 0, 0 1, 1, 0 1, 1.
First column is added as a bias.
So now my, in the, in the input,
I have 3, 3, 3 inputs for each row.
I have three inputs. One, which is represents the bias.
Zero, zero represents the actual inputs of the end
for the two inputs, right?
So this, this, this is my end.
Uh, similarly for rx,
I'm adding bias up, uh, in the first column.
And for xor also, I'm adding bias for the first column.
Now, this particular, uh, this particular code is for the,
uh, uh, dot product,
because we have to do weighted sum W into X.
So this is the function predict which we are defining.
And what we are doing, we are just, uh, uh,
doing the dot product between W and two x.
And that will give, give us the J
and this will pass it through the active,
uh, sorry, step function.
Activation function is a step function here.
So step function, the way it works,
that is greater than zero, then it'll return one other way.
It'll return zero. So this whole, uh, this will
complete my weighted sum plus, uh, by, uh, bias
or weighted sum includes the bias here.
So weighted sum, followed by the activation function.
This, this, uh, this is the function for that.
This is the function for my perceptron. Okay?
So this is the perceptron representation.
Now, we need to train this perceptron.
So we'll call this perceptron. So train perceptron function.
And what we are doing here is, uh, we will first, uh,
we, we can decide how many APOC we want to run.
Here. It is set as 50 apoc.
And every time when we get a line, we will change.
We'll update our weights
for the misclassification cases, right?
So that's why learning rate is set as zero and 0.1 x
and Y is my input and output for whatever X or, and, or,
or whatever for everything, it'll work.
So X and Y is my input and output.
Now, what we are doing is every time we take one, one row
as an input, because we have four row
0, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0, 1, 1.
So this particular line, uh, this for loop will work
for row by row.
And we'll take the first row, first row,
it'll feed it, uh, three inputs.
First one is the bias. Next two are the actual inputs.
So that will be, that will come in,
X si corresponding target will come in.
Y we'll do the, we'll call the predict function,
which we have defined here.
It'll give either one or zero as an output.
And that we are going to calculate the error.
So if the Y hat is exactly at YI error will be zero.
Otherwise, we'll get some error, uh,
like minus one or plus one.
That will be your error. And
accordingly, what you will do is you will
change the weights.
And every time, after every iteration,
whatever weight changes is happening
that I'm storing in this weight history,
which initially we defined empty list,
and every time we are appending, okay?
Uh, the new weights into it.
So new weights are coming as w
and that I'm impending, uh, with a clone, fine.
So it is creating a copy of it, that's all.
So this is my, uh, training.
And now we are plotting the decision boundary,
plotting the decision boundary.
So here it'll look like.
So, uh, here you see, once we have, uh,
done this, this is the end gate.
A line clearly separates the blue and red line.
This is the, or a line clearly separates the blue
and orange, uh, sorry, uh, blue and red line.
And finally, this is exor.
You can see that there is a line,
but it is not able to separate, it is not able
to separate the blue, uh,
because it's a non-linearly separable data.
So whatever straight line, wherever you want to put
with a single perception, you cannot solve this problem.
This is what we were talking,
and we have seen, uh, with the, the visualization also,
and we have seen with the demo also.
So the point is, what is the solution for this? Okay?
And now we have seen the problem.
What is the solution for this solution?
We have already seen single perceptron cannot do that job,
but multi-layer perceptron can do that job, right?
And this is, this slide shows the exactly same thing
for exor X one, X two.
Uh, we have, we are feeding the input
and we are adding one hidden layer in between
with two neurons, okay?
Which is known, which is shown here as H one and S two.
And, uh, the output from H one S two will go
for the final layer perceptron.
And this perceptron will give us the output.
So when you have the network, uh, like this,
then it'll be able to, uh, it'll be able to separate, uh,
the, the class one or class zero, even in the case of xor.
And so just this particular slide, uh, I wanted to show, to
show you what exactly happens when, uh,
we have seen the visualization that it's okay,
but what happens here?
So, uh, what happens when you add one hidden layer in
between the raw inputs are represented in some other form.
So we are doing the representation pro,
we are changing the input representation.
So initial input was like,
say 0, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0, and one, one.
We are not able to separate with the straight line, right?
So this zero, zero
or XX one, X two later on is being converted as H one S two.
Okay? So this, when, when you will do this calculation,
all the weights and inputs are given to you.
This zero zero will be converted as at zero zero itself.
So if you'll pass this zero into 1 0, 0 into one zero,
and this, uh, bias is also plus one into zero zero.
So it'll come zero, right?
Similarly, for X, the S two will also come zero.
So for zero, zero H one S two will be also zero, zero.
But for zero one, you will,
if you will calculate all these things,
H one s two will give the output as one zero.
You substitute all these value, you will get
that for one zero.
Also, the output would be one zero itself.
So see that what is the change for zero,
zero H one S two is zero, zero for zero.
One, H one S two is one zero for one,
zero H one s two is one zero.
And for one, one, the H one has two H, two one.
Now this is the transformed input.
You can, uh, uh, think like that.
So I have transformed my input.
So what change it has brought.
So earlier my data points were like this, zero, zero,
and this is 1 0, 0 1, and one one.
But now transformed input is being represented like that.
This is zero, zero, right? This is one zero.
And here you have two times one zero, like one zero.
There are two points. So they're overlapped on each other.
So this is the same point which are
representing these 2, 1 0, 1 0.
And this particular point is representing two comm one.
And now you can see that you can easily place a, a,
a line like this, which can, which is able
to separate the two class of data.
Okay? Now, this is, this is, uh, another way
of understanding that how we are, uh, representing
our non-linear data,
non-linear de separable data into the linear space.
And then we are putting a line
to separate the two class, okay?
This is another way, and same thing is being shown here in
the form of demo as well.
I'll quickly show you that we'll quickly, oh,
uh, show you this one.
So here we are represent, uh, importing all the, uh,
importing all the, uh, packages.
And this, uh, let me just, uh, run this.
So here, what we are doing is creating our tensors.
So 0, 0, 0, 1, 1, 0 1, 1. Same thing, X and Y for the xr.
And I'm trying to plot it just to see
that initially, how does it look?
So initially it'll look something like that, right?
So non-linearly separable data point,
you can clearly see that, right?
Okay. So what we have to do is we have to design a network
to convert this non-linearity separable data
and represent it in some other form.
And that is what you will see.
Now, before that, we are adding a bias upfront.
And then see there are two layers in the secal layer.
We are going to use the radio activation function,
which introduce the nonlinearity in into your network.
And then the output layer, we are
still using the step function.
So this is the, uh, this is the functions for that.
Now, uh, we are initializing our weights minus one,
same weights, which we have, which we have seen here,
the same, same, uh, weights is taken here.
Okay? So W one is the weights between input and hidden,
and W2 is a set of weights between hidden and output layer.
Okay? So that is what it is being initialized here.
And then we are creating the forward, uh, uh, propagation,
uh, for this, this network that, first of all,
we do the dot product between W and two X store into ZJ one
and J one is buying passed
through the relu activation function as edge.
Now, this edge will have H one S two, remember?
So it's, uh, for H one S two, both,
we are calculating this one, okay?
And these are all the vectors.
These W is a vectors X, uh, uh, so it, this Z one,
uh, will give you Z one and uh, Z two,
and then H will give you H one and S two.
This will give you two, two values, okay?
And then what we are doing is whatever we are getting,
H one S two, we are adding a bias again,
because for the second layer, also, we have a bias.
You see that this is a bias, which is connecting
to the second layer also here for Y one.
So that bias is being added here
in this slide add bias term.
And then what we are doing is, again,
we are creating the dot product, dot product between the W2.
So this layer weight, I'm seeing a W2
and dot product between W2
and HH represents H one and H two.
That is what is written here.
W2 into H with bias will give you J two, pass it through
that step function, you will get the final prediction Y hat.
So this is what is the forward pass.
And now this line is source that,
okay, what exactly happens?
Zero, zero. Now it is giving the output
as 1, 1, 1, 1 and rest.
Two between, uh, input 0 1, 1 0 going the output as zero,
which is the correct output for exor.
Now, when I tried plotting that, that, okay,
what exactly happened?
So this is how it looks like. Yeah.
Now see that, so my, this is one data point.
So my data points look like that.
My initial input, which was 0 0, 0 1, 1, 0 1 1
is not transformed as zero 1.50, 0.50,
0.5, and one zero.
This is what happened with H one S two,
and I have explained here also, this is
what happened here in between.
So this one, when you will plot,
you will have now only three points.
This is, this represents zero and 0.5.
This re this blue represent zero and 1.5
and two data points are representing zero and 1.5,
and this represent one and zero.
And now you can easily place, uh,
now you can easily place a decision boundary, which,
which can separate these two, uh, class of data.
This is the same plot as, uh, which you're seeing here.
Only thing is the H one
and S two, the X axis yxi range has changed.
Here it is between 0, 1 0 and 1.5.
And here it is little different minus one
and two minus 1.510, but it is the same data point, okay?
But we can see that now we have got that line.
So we have solved that, uh, hard problem
by introducing one more layer in between.
Okay? Uh, uh,
before I will, uh, stop for the, uh, questions,
because this much you must have known.
I'll quickly show you the different, uh, uh,
because we have another 10 minutes.
Uh, I'll show you a few more.
Slide three, four more slide where I'll show you, okay?
How can then this multi-layer perception idea
or, uh, two layer or three layer perception can be used
for the different, different problems
or for different, different types of the outputs.
So this is one such network.
What you can create where you have n number of inputs,
you have one hidden layer, one output layer,
and the output layer, you have n number of neurons.
That means that you can use it
for the multi-class classification, uh,
uh, problem.
Okay? The only thing is what we are, uh,
doing here is everything is same.
See that H how do we calculate by weighted sum?
W into X, okay? Plus B, B is this particular part, okay?
The WX plus B,
we are putting one activation function here at this
particular, uh, layer.
So that activation function can be anything sigmoid, uh,
here represented, but can be anything.
Now that will give us, h,
h represents everything H one, H two, H three.
So it's a vector.
And now this edge is being multiplied with this set
of weight U and then it gives us Z
and z We are passing through the softmax.
Why is softmax here? Because it's a multi-layer classi, uh,
multi, uh, multi-class classification problem.
And then softmax physical give us the probability
distribution across these outputs,
and we, it it'll be easy for us
to choose one output which has the highest probability.
So that's the part, uh, you can, so this is
how you can use this, uh, two layer
or multi-layer perception
or multi-class classification problem.
Now, this slide is same. Here.
We are simply replacing the bias with the X node
to make our, uh, representation a little bit easier.
So WX plus B is now represented at wx,
which also includes the bias.
Nothing different.
Now, uh, what, what are the different purposes you can use?
You can use the single perceptron as a binary
logistic regression problem, right?
Because it'll give, give us the probability,
you can decide which class it's,
and you have the set of inputs, okay?
You can also use this, uh, this type of network
for multinomial logistic regression problem only changes.
Now you have multiple outputs,
multiple neurons at the output layer, soft max,
you can put just now we have seen,
and we can get the multi-class classification problem easily
done here using the soft max activation function.
Okay? Now, you can also have the two layer, uh, network
with the scaler output, okay?
Say the two layer, but you want the single say,
binary classification problem, or you can have the two
layers neural network with the,
say the multi-class classification problem.
You can also do this kind of network, use this kind
of network for the regression problem only thing is at the
output layer, instead of using sigmoid,
you can use the linear activation.
So then you can use it for the regression problem.
So likewise, you can see that, right?
It's a lot of flexibility.
You have fixed set of inputs
and you know what output you want,
but then in between everything is flexible.
You may keep as many hidden layers as you want.
You may keep as many neurons in the hidden layer
as you want, right?
So everything is flexible.
Then based on the output, what you want,
you can design the output layer.
You can place number of neurons in the output layer.
Everything is quite flexible.
And for that one, we have different,
different activation functions available for,
for a particular, uh, type of output and all.
So with the practice, you will get to know that when to use
what activation function in which layer and all,
and how to design this network, how to place, uh,
the neurons in a, a layer, how many neurons.
And although there is no fixed rule to, for,
for keeping number of neurons in a layer,
how many neurons we can keep, how many layers we can keep.
But with the practice, you will get some, uh, idea
and then on you can be able to construct the different,
different neuron.
Okay? So I, I guess I'll stop here today.
Uh, you can ask the questions.
In the next class, we will go with the back propagation, uh,
right, and we'll see how the back propagation works.
Yes, sir. So here each, uh,
as in multi-class classification, each neuron
represent one class, sir.
For example, in binary we have multiple neuron.
Then how the class will be distributed within the neurons.
No, uh, I suppose you have binary
class classification problem.
Yes. That you use this kind of network architecture
where you have a single neuron, uh, stating
that based on the probability,
you can decide whether it is class one.
What what we do in the case of logistic regression.
So you don't use multiple neurons at the output layer.
Suppose you have binary classification problem,
but if you have multi-class classification problem,
then you can add 2, 3, 4, whatever number of,
uh, uh, class you have.
Yeah,
Thank you, Sir.
Um, like this hidden layer, uh,
what happens when we keep on increase, uh, number
of neurons in this?
Uh, I, I have shown you one visualization right here.
Yeah. Uh, I guess the, that will give you, you try, uh,
what, what I'll suggest to you,
this visualization is really good.
You keep on adding, uh, the neurons in this.
You see that what happens, so with the,
with the D six neuron, this is what is happening, okay?
And then say that I'll stop here,
I'll add one more neuron, okay?
What will happen? And you may, uh, okay,
you may see in variations in, in terms of the acal,
so maybe one more neuron may take less number of hippo to
for this convergence.
And all right, uh, you may add one more neuron,
you may add tender, so you can keep on adding
and then checking that what is happening.
This will give you better
understanding that what is happening.
So, uh, you, you see this one more layer I have added,
and this is what has happened only with the
less than 50 ocs, it was converged.
That was, that was not the case when I was having, uh, this,
this only one hidden layer, it, there, it had taken, uh,
some number of ocs.
So this is what you have to observe what is happening,
see at the initial levels and
had given you some clue, right?
That what is happening when we add layers, uh, two layer,
three layer and, and, and, uh, two neurons in the layer
and three neuro, uh, neurons in the layer.
But when it goes to the multi multiple head layers
and a hundred neurons in the, uh, in a particular layer,
it is very difficult to answer that question,
what you have said, but you can always observe that
with this kind of visualization, okay?
Yes.
Uh, after seeing this visualization, uh, I mean I got, uh,
have a, had a clarity that I thought
that initially adding a hidden, um,
adding a neutrons in the hidden layer might, uh,
caused the performance.
But after seeing here the visualization, I got a clarity
that, uh, adding a hidden, uh, sorry, new, uh,
neutron in this, uh, hidden lens will, uh,
give the solution very quickly,
Correct? Correct.
But later on you will see
that if you'll have, say that you, the three neurons,
four neurons are able to solve the problem
and you have added 15 neurons just for the reason, just say
that first of all, it'll increase the complexity.
You have to do any calculation
because weights, wire are connected and all.
Secondly, you will see
that many neurons are doing almost similar job,
many neurons, because you see this here,
every neuron is trying
to capture one part in some pattern in the data,
this pattern, this pattern, this, this.
And, but if you'll keep on adding this, keep on adding this,
what will happen, you'll see that, okay,
there are several neurons which is trying to, which,
which has the same information, trying
to have the same information in the dataset.
And that's where this over fitting problems again,
comes into the picture and we need some kind
of regularization technique.
So, uh, it's fine that, uh, uh, you can add as many neurons
as you want in the head and layer and all,
but, uh, yeah, it may lead us to the complexity.
See how many complexities now, how many connections,
you can see all these other weights and biases
and uh, secondly, it may also lead it to the over fitting
or, uh, uh, yeah.
So those prob kind of problems
may also come into the picture.
One more, doctor, sir, uh, while, um, calculating here,
hidden player, uh, can we have any technique
or logic so that for example, let's say hidden, uh,
this perception 1, 2, 3 in hidden layers, whatever their,
uh, workload that can be stored
and that can be passed on the information that, uh, these,
uh, for these uh, points, I have workload like that.
So it can reduce the time. And
Uh, I see that there are, uh, some, some you can store
that whatever is the output from the hidden layer,
you can definitely store that.
That is what I'll show you in the next class also.
But here also I have done that.
So I, when I showed you this one that what is the,
what is the au output from this, this particular,
uh, uh, hidden points?
I store that one actually. So you can do that.
Even the weights, you can store that. Yeah.
Okay. Thank you Sir. Everything is possible. Yeah,
Yeah. Uh, Sunil
just wanted to mention one point, yes.
Um, um, since, uh, I think Deepak asked, no,
what happens when you go on increase number,
you answered all the points.
So just to connect what you answered with
what I explained earlier.
See, as you increase the number of neurons, you'll be able
to, uh, know construct a more complicated hyper surface,
which will help you in, uh, dealing
with classes which have a very complicated hyper surf need
of complicated hyper to separate
the examples of the classes.
But as Dr.
Uh, Sunil mentioned, you were, you were class
or by machine learning task is a very straightforward task,
very simple, hyper can, can separate.
You go on adding the neurons, you are overkill the problem.
So as a result, no overfeeding, everything will happen.
So that is why there is no, there is no standard, uh,
um, algorithm
or equation, which says it has
to have only this much neurons.
So depending on the, you know, complexity of the problem,
we can try to play around with the neurons in each.
That is the way people do it.
But only, uh, the, the conation is,
um, the neural networks show a graceful
degradation in the performance.
That means to say, suppose assume that
for any purpose you need 15 neurons in a layer,
even if you make it 40
or make it 60, performance doesn't change so drastically.
Of course you need 15 neurons, you'll use only five neurons.
Naturally it'll degrade.
But uh, see in a mathematical equation point of view,
if you know the exact equation,
that equation gives you output as 50.
You're expected to put only 15 neurons.
But this, see here it is by more
by heuristic approach.
So that's where, uh, there are no single answer for that,
which you can get it from mathematical question,
but for a simple task, you are overdoing with more neurons,
more computations, less data.
Maybe there over fitting happens.
And if you require more neurons
but you have very less number of neurons,
then it is not learning the discrimative ability
because the hyper surface is not getting
constructed in the required way.
So this is the trade off we have to do.
Yeah, uh, sir, we can also even see that when we have a,
a, a model, uh, using set of neurons, so we can see for
that validation laws
and training laws, so they will come to know
how much neurons we are under, under added or over added.
So based on the loss pattern, also we can able
to take on inference whether we are added less number
of neurons or more accordingly we can correct the model.
Yeah, that is an indirect way of seeing suppose, you know,
what we want is uh, the validation data.
Also, we need very high performance and the training data.
Also, we need high performance.
We make a trade off between the two cases.
Unseen data, seen data from seen data
gives me a hundred percent.
I'm quite happy it has learned. Then it is a over fit K.
And whereas the validation set gives 50%, that means
to say it has over fit for the, uh, given data.
That means to say there are some neurons which are
duplicating, then we might have to reduce the neurons,
and then I run the program, then validation start increase.
So this is no like a crossover line between the
training loss and validation loss
based around that people do it.
But otherwise, beyond that, I don't, uh,
have any exact relationship.
No. Okay, this loss is there 50%, can I make, uh, neurons,
even neurons, uh, 50%, that type of relation is not there.
Yes. Okay.
Thank you. Okay.
Then all the slides are uploaded.
Kindly go through it, do the practice.
All the notebooks are also uploaded.
Keep on doing the practice, please. Yeah.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you, sir. Sir, thank you sir.
Thank you. Sir. Can you call me back? Thank you, sir.
Sure, sir. You have my mobile number.
Uh, I don't type it here in the Sure, sure.
It's my WhatsApp number also. Please call me back. That's.